The Kaiser Family Foundation is
a nonprofit organization focusing on national health issues,
as well as the U.S. role in global health policy.
This 2013 Kaiser Family Foundation data shows
that uninsured people receive substantially less healthcare than the insured.
This 2015 data shows that the uninsured are likely to have no regular source of care,
to postpone or do without needed care,
or to postpone or not get needed prescriptions due to cost.
Kaiser Family Foundation goes on to say that
insured and uninsured people who are injured or newly diagnosed with a chronic condition,
such as diabetes or hypertension,
receive similar plans for follow-up care from their physician.
People without health coverage are less likely to obtain
all the recommended services than those with coverage.
Finally, because the uninsured are less likely to have regular outpatient care,
they are more likely to end up with expensive hospitalizations for
avoidable health problems and to experienced declines in their overall health.
When hospitalized, uninsured people receive
fewer diagnostic and therapeutic services
and have higher mortality rates than those with insurance.